Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Have you ever wondered why some reflections seem to catch a supervisor's
这些原则都同样适用。竞赛还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的内容吧。你有没有想过，为什么有些反思似乎能抓住主管
or recruiter's attention and others just seem to fall a little flat? Reflections are a way to show not just what you've done, but what you've learned from those experiences and why it matters. Whether it's in person or on application forms, what is the secret formula for reflecting in a way that really impresses? In this episode, I'll share my exact strategies, and I'm also going to be chucking in my examples of what works and what really doesn't. Hi, welcome along. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, and it's lovely to have you here. One of the most common questions I am asked as a qualified clinical psychologist is when I'm doing the compassionate Q&As for interview and application
或招聘人员的注意力，而另一些却显得平淡无奇？反思不仅是一种展示你做了什么的方式，更是展示你从这些经历中学到了什么以及为什么这些经历很重要的方式。无论是在面试现场还是在申请表上，能够真正打动人的反思秘诀是什么？在这一集中，我将分享我的具体策略，并会列举一些有效的和无效的例子。嗨，欢迎收听。我是Marianne Trent博士，很高兴你能来。作为一名合格的临床心理学家，在面试和申请
season, or when I am running my aspiring psychologist membership sessions, is how can I reflect in a way that really demonstrates that I am not just going through the motions. How can I do what I need to be doing at this stage of my career to be getting the green light to proceed to the next stage? So the reflecting that we're talking about is, of course, the ability to be able to look at your experiences and to think about how they've shaped you and what you've learned from them, rather than just your experience of observing the processes involved
季进行同理心问答，或者主持“有抱负的心理学家会员”会议时，我最常被问到的问题之一是：我该如何进行反思，才能真正证明我不仅仅是在走过场？我该如何在职业生涯的这个阶段做我需要做的事情，从而获得进入下一阶段的绿灯？我们所说的反思，当然是指能够审视自己的经历，思考它们如何塑造了你，以及你从中学到了什么，而不是仅仅观察所涉及的过程。
in what took place. Ultimately, what we want for you is for you to be compassionate, reflective practitioners. We don't want you to be robots that aren't affected by the clients you serve, that aren't moved by their distress and that therefore don't really help you to create meaningful, effective interventions or assessments or treatment plans that help clients to get results. And I think one of the best ways to demonstrate that is to be reflective, to really think and join up the dots of what being in this role or in these different job roles has been like, how it's shaped you, how it's affected you, what trace it's left upon you, in a good or sometimes in a not so good way. So your ability to reflect both in person, in interviews, in supervision, on job applications are really going to help you stand out in these incredibly competitive job arenas that you find yourself in. It might be that you're after an assistant psychologist job, It might be that you're after an assistant psychologist job,
最终，我们希望你成为富有同情心的反思型从业者。我们不希望你成为机器人，不被服务的客户所影响，不被他们的痛苦所触动，从而无法帮助自己制定有意义、有效的干预措施、评估或治疗计划来帮助客户获得成果。我认为展示这一点最好的方法之一就是进行反思，真正思考并将你在这些角色或不同工作岗位上的经历联系起来，思考它们如何塑造了你，如何影响了你，以及它们在你身上留下了什么痕迹，无论是好的还是有时不太好的。因此，你在面试、督导、求职申请中进行反思的能力，真的会帮助你在竞争极其激烈的就业市场中脱颖而出。也许你正在寻找一份助理心理学家的工作，
it might be that you're after a trainee job or a PWP training role or even a qualified role for that matter. And these skills that I'm going to be outlining today could well be the difference that makes the difference for you. Okay so let's crack on. What are the key elements that make a really great reflection? So firstly we are going to want to describe the key elements that make a really great reflection so firstly we are going to want to describe the situation but not in a way that is too wordy so for example you might say when i was working as an assistant psychologist i worked with a client with severe anxiety that really helps us set the tone the flavor the context we've kind of got an idea of what you're doing when and in what capacity you were working. We only need to be producing the most relevant
也许你正在寻找一份实习工作、PWP培训岗位，甚至是合格的职位。我今天概述的这些技能可能就是让你与众不同的关键。好了，让我们开始吧。是什么关键要素构成了一次非常棒的反思？首先，我们要描述关键要素，但不要过于冗长。例如，你可以说“当我担任助理心理学家时，我曾与一位患有严重焦虑症的客户合作”。这有助于设定基调、风格和背景，让我们大致了解你在何时、以何种身份工作。我们只需要提供最相关、
important information here. We don't want to be adding extra unnecessary detail. We certainly don't want to be adding identifiable client information. The next stage is we're going to be analyzing what we have learned from this experience or these experiences. So this is where we are beginning to go above and beyond, you know, the building blocks of two plus two equals four. This is where we're really starting to do something special and to transform the kind of raw ingredients we've been given to something truly exceptional. So you might say, for example, this experience taught me to really use my active listening skills and how to adapt my communication skills so that the client could get the best out of the sessions.
最重要的信息。我们不需要添加额外不必要的细节。我们当然更不能添加可识别的客户信息。下一个阶段是分析我们从这些经历中学到了什么。这是我们开始超越基础知识（比如2+2=4）的地方。这是我们真正开始做一些特别的事情，并将我们所获得的原始素材转化为真正卓越成果的地方。例如，你可以说：“这段经历教会了我真正运用积极倾听技巧，并调整沟通方式，以便客户能从会话中获得最大收益。”
And then an area often overlooked in reflections is how we are going to build on this for the future, how it's going to connect with us so that we have a different experience, also that we continue to gain from this best practice experience. So you might say now I've had these experience of interventions working really well, it's empowered me to think about how I can really think about the importance of rapport building with clients and how to make sure that it's effective, whether we're doing regular check-ins, whether we're doing outcome measures, so, whether we're, you know, doing outcome
接下来是一个在反思中经常被忽视的领域：我们未来将如何在此基础上进一步发展，它将如何与我们连接，以便我们获得不同的体验，并继续从这种最佳实践经验中获益。所以你可以说：“现在我有了这些干预措施运作良好的经验，这使我有能力思考如何真正重视与客户建立融洽关系，以及如何确保其有效性，无论是通过定期检查，还是进行结果测量，
measures, so that we're really getting in client feedback so that they can benefit from what we're doing. Ultimately, that's great for the client, but it's also great for our services outcome measures too. What are the common mistakes people are making when they are reflecting? Well, the first I would say is being too descriptive, just going on and on and on. And, you know, when you're listening to someone do that, it can be really hard to keep track of. And you kind of find yourself wondering where it's going and whether they're ever going to get to the point. We also really want to be avoiding just giving the nuts and bolts, the bare essentials of what happened, but never kind of offering any insight
以便我们真正获得客户反馈，让他们从我们的工作中受益。归根结底，这对客户来说很好，对我们服务的成果衡量也很好。人们在反思时常犯的错误是什么？我认为第一个就是过于描述性，没完没了地讲。当你听别人这样做时，很难跟上思路。你会不禁怀疑他们到底想表达什么，以及他们是否能说到点子上。我们还必须避免只提供事情的来龙去脉和基本要素，却从不提供任何洞察力
or anything like a little bit of extra magic on that. It's just purely descriptive. That is what we don't want to do. So we don't want to be saying, I observed therapy sessions and I found them really interesting. You know, so what? We also don't want to be, you know, too overgeneralized here or, you know, not really making exciting, engaging, insightful comments and reflections. We don't want to just be wanging in and that's made me more empathic. So it can be really helpful to put in some theory or some models that kind of you are using to shape your thinking. Perhaps you're linking it back to, you know, psychology theory, you know, key studies that you've learned about in psychology. You know, we're really trying to think about linking that theory and practice and trying to
或任何额外的亮点。如果只是纯粹的描述，那不是我们想要的。所以我们不要说“我观察了治疗过程，觉得很有趣”。那又怎样？我们也不要过于笼统，或者没有做出令人兴奋、引人入胜、深刻的评论和反思。我们不想只是随口说“这让我变得更有同理心了”。引入一些你用来塑造思维的理论或模型会非常有帮助。也许你可以将其与心理学理论或你在心理学中学到的关键研究联系起来。我们真的在尝试将理论与实践联系起来，并试图
demonstrate that your knowledge isn't just surface level. Let's dive in and have a little bit of a look at some examples that aren't quite hitting the mark and some which are better. So for example, if somebody said, I observed a client session which I found interesting and it showed me how CBT works, I would say that lacks depth, it lacks any kind of actual emotional connection, It lacks any personal insight or resonance to you as a person, a clinician, a human. Let's see if we can come up with something a little bit better. Observing a CBT session helped me understand how a structured approach can alleviate anxiety. I noticed how the therapist used Socratic questioning, which I later practiced under supervision. This
证明你的知识不仅仅停留在表面。让我们深入探讨一些不太理想的例子，以及一些更好的例子。例如，如果有人说：“我观察了一次客户会话，觉得很有趣，它向我展示了CBT是如何运作的。”我会说这缺乏深度，缺乏任何实际的情感联系，缺乏作为一个人、一名临床医生或一个人类的个人洞察力或共鸣。让我们看看能不能想出更好的表达。例如：“观察CBT会话帮助我理解了结构化方法如何缓解焦虑。我注意到治疗师是如何使用苏格拉底式提问的，我后来在督导下练习了这一点。这
experience highlighted the importance of tailoring interventions to individual clients' needs. So why is that better? What are the strengths of an answer like that? I think it's got that clear learning, it's got some theory, and it's got an idea of what we've taken from that experience and how it informs our learning. It shows us that that's an active process, that you know that things aren't just happening in a vacuum, that we are being shaped and we are learning and we're growing as we go and that is what we want. Of course these skills in reflection don't come easily to everybody, it's so dependent on the way that we've been brought up the kind of conversations that we have with friends with family with our supervisors the kind of developmental opportunities we have had
段经历突显了根据个人客户需求量身定制干预措施的重要性。”为什么这样更好？这种回答的优势是什么？我认为它有清晰的学习点，有理论支持，并且有关于我们从经验中获得了什么以及它如何指导我们学习的想法。它向我们展示了这是一个主动的过程，你明白事情不是在真空中发生的，我们正在被塑造，我们正在学习，我们正在成长，这就是我们想要的。当然，这些反思技能并非每个人都能轻易掌握，它非常依赖于我们的成长方式、我们与朋友、家人、主管进行的对话，以及我们所拥有的发展机会，
along the way so how can we begin to cultivate these skills if it's not already part of our comfortable wheelhouse one of the top tips I used was that I had a reflective journal and that bad boy would come out you know after supervision sessions, after clinical sessions, after delivering neuropsych, after team meetings, after ward round, after you know discussions with my peers, after lunchtime sometimes, after attending assistant psychologist meetings. It was kind of always with me and I'd be able to just jot things down as and when they cropped up for me. I was using it to compare and contrast my current self to my future selves, to my past selves,
一路走来，如果这些技能还不是你的强项，我们该如何开始培养它们呢？我使用的顶级技巧之一是拥有一本反思日记。那个“坏小子”会在督导会议后、临床会话后、进行神经心理学评估后、团队会议后、查房后、与同事讨论后、午餐后，有时在参加助理心理学家会议后拿出来。它几乎总是随身携带，我可以在事情发生时随时记下。我用它来比较和对比现在的自己与未来的自己、过去的自己，
to think about what I want to learn, how I can further myself, how I can develop. How has what I've done compared to my previous interventions? What have I learned? What did I notice that I did differently? What did I notice that I'd like to do differently next time? Another top tip is to seek feedback. That might be from your supervisor, your manager. It might be from your peers. How do they feel that you are
思考我想学什么，我如何提升自己，我如何发展。我所做的事情与之前的干预措施相比如何？我学到了什么？我注意到我做了什么不同的事情？我注意到下次我想做哪些不同的事情？另一个顶级技巧是寻求反馈。这可能来自你的主管、经理，也可能来自你的同事。他们觉得你作为一名反思型从业者，
developing as a reflective practitioner? Both for your journaling and for your supervision sessions, it might be that you're asking questions like, what did I learn? What could I do better? How was I shaped by this experience? And of course, thinking about actual models for reflecting can be a really useful thing to do as well. Please do let me know in the comments if an additional video on different reflecting models might be helpful, such as the Gibbs reflective cycle, as using methods like that can really help you to structure your answers and to maximise your progress. Whether you are watching or listening to this content, it would be so gratefully received if you could like drop a comment or just let me know what your top tips for reflecting are. How have you been able to supercharge your skills for reflection? And how
发展得如何？无论是为了写日记还是为了督导会议，你都可以问这样的问题：“我学到了什么？我能做得更好吗？这段经历是如何塑造我的？”当然，思考实际的反思模型也是非常有用的。如果需要关于不同反思模型的额外视频（例如吉布斯反思循环），请在评论中告诉我，因为使用这样的方法可以真正帮助你构建答案并最大化你的进步。无论你是观看还是收听此内容，如果你能点赞、评论或告诉我你的反思秘诀，我将不胜感激。你是如何增强反思技能的？以及你如何
are you reaping the benefits? So to summarize, a great reflection will include description, analysis, with the application being what you've learned and what you hope to apply in future. And really, we've got to do this super, super regularly. We've got to be weaving this in to our day-to-day moment-to-moment practices. Might be that you're thinking about this when you're showering, when you're cooking, when you're running, when you're on the treadmill. You know, this could be cropping up at random times. I used to reflect a lot when I was driving and stuck in traffic. And we're going to need to come back to this. It is not a one-and-done approach. If you've got kind
从中获益？总结一下，一次伟大的反思将包括描述、分析，并将所学内容应用于未来。我们必须非常、非常定期地这样做。我们必须将其融入到我们日常的每一刻实践中。也许你在洗澡、做饭、跑步或在跑步机上时会想到这一点。你知道，这可能会在随机的时间出现。我过去在开车或堵车时经常反思。我们需要不断回到这一点。这不是一次性的方法。如果你有那种
of stock answers that you use on application forms then we're going to need to keep checking those because I honestly believe that we ought to be changing, growing, shaping and just you know becoming a better and better human and clinician you know from day to day, week to week. So we shouldn't just be wanging in those same job applications or same kind of doctorate applications each year. I would urge you to have regular reviews and check-ins with yourself and with your supervisor because your skills and your practices across the board, including in reflection, should be advancing all of the time. I really hope that you find this content helpful. If you do, please do take a moment to like the content to engage with it to
在申请表上使用的固定答案，那么我们需要不断检查它们，因为我真心认为我们应该每天、每周都在改变、成长、塑造，并成为更好的人和临床医生。所以我们不应该每年都提交那些相同的求职申请或博士申请。我敦促你对自己和主管进行定期的回顾和检查，因为你在各个方面的技能和实践，包括反思，都应该一直在进步。我真心希望你觉得这些内容有帮助。如果确实如此，请花点时间点赞、参与互动，
comment to share to tell your friends it really is the kindest free thing you can do if you did want to buy me a cup of herbal tea to say thank you then please do check out the link in any of my social media bios please do also come along to my free facebook group the aspiring psychologist community and if it's your time and you're ready for the next step, please do consider the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective and the Clinical Psychologist Collective are also really great books which will help you to build on your reflective practice and to see
评论、分享并告诉你的朋友，这真的是你能做的最友善的免费举动。如果你想买一杯草药茶来感谢我，请查看我社交媒体简介中的链接。也请加入我的免费Facebook群组“有抱负的心理学家社区”。如果时机成熟，你准备好迈出下一步，请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”，每月仅需30英镑，无最低期限要求。《有抱负的心理学家集体》和《临床心理学家集体》也是非常棒的书籍，将帮助你建立反思实践并看到
how others put that into practice too. If you need to reflect on grief or on autism, then please do check out the Grief Collective and the Autistic Anthology. with this podcast that you're sad you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that
其他人是如何将其付诸实践的。如果你需要反思悲伤或自闭症，请查看《悲伤集体》和《自闭症选集》。通过这个播客，你离获得资格更近了一步。我是Yana，一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，发现关于各种不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，
no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我知道我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。